Olga rojas es vecina desde hace más de
40 años de Plaza Italia el centro de las
manifestaciones del estallido Social
chileno en 2019 vivió de cerca como su
comunidad se convirtió en un campo de
batalla las cicatrices aún son visibles
en los muros las calles e incluso las
veredas ahora el barrio vuelve poco a
poco a la normalidad se plantan flores
limpian fachadas los departamentos se
vuelven a alquilar Olga está contenta
por la recuperación del lugar
no podía prender la luz no podía ir a
trabajar no podía salir a comprar
angustiante muy angustiante y me
evacuaban tres veces al día los bomberos
porque siempre había fuego abajo a su
casa llegaron incluso disparos en la
ventana pensaron que habían cámaras una
cosa así ese tiempo quedó atrás también
para aquellos que tienen negocios en la
zona y que sufrieron pérdidas estimadas
en más de 130 millones de dólares en el
sector según el último catastro en esta
Vereda muy cercana donde se registraban
los enfrentamientos solo 3 de 17
negocios permanecen abiertos Carlos Siri
administra uno la antigua fuente uno de
los clásicos del barrio antes siempre
rebosante de gente
he ido recuperando pero nosotros estamos
en términos reales parados en una venta
que sería como el 60% de lo que
vendíamos o sea todavía falta mucho para
alcanzar los niveles quizás que teníamos
las autoridades del gobierno regional
han previsto 100 actividades culturales
para tratar de devolver la vida al
barrio entre ellas Esta obra de teatro
que Valeria una enfermera acude a ver
con toda su familia volver a Santiago
nuevamente y sentirse seguro la verdad
que es un tema que aún nos cuesta pero
creo que esta iniciativa nos va a
entregar eso esta seguridad es poder
volver nuevamente a nuestras calles a
nuestra ciudad si en actividades
culturales para cicatrizar heridas
sociales y retomar poco a poco una parte
de la ciudad y un espacio simbólico
cargado todavía de mucha emocionalidad